ladies and gentlemen as you know IAM we
have met here tonight to inaugurate the
exhibition 1989 The Velvet Revolution
the event was prepared in the
collaboration of the vice-president of
the European Commission mr. Marshall
Javitch member of the European
Commission madam veeraiah rava permanent
representation of the Czech Republic to
the European Union permanent
representation of the Slovak Republic to
the European Union and the Czech central
Brussels and now the time is for the
opening speeches so let me please invite
all the speakers here with me to the
stage
[Applause]
so let me present to you now the
vice-president of the European
Commission mr. marechal Javitch for the
first opening remarks thank you very
much good evening to all of you it's
really very symbolic and hard forming to
have the possibility to really mark this
very special occasion for all of us here
in Berlin and I really would like to
welcome in particular my colleague not
only the Commissioner about
vice-president basicnet Vieira Urawa
with whom we've been really the best
bodies in the current European
Commission but also my colleague
Commissioner still Ian eNOS who is also
man of great knowledge personal warm and
great charm and I'm very much
appreciating the fact that you are here
but of course two of my close colleagues
and Friends Miroslav will attract not
only the foreign minister of Slovakia
but my friend of many years and
ambassador of Czech Republic mr. doar
with whom we also have a lot of a lot of
common stories and if I'm looking in the
audience I see my friends members of the
European Parliament I see my first boss
here from the Federal Foreign Minister
mr. kovanda
and I and I see a lot of friends and
colleagues from the time of the of the
Velvet Revolution and I know them all
because this was the moment which we
very often discussed together because I
think definitely for me this was the few
weeks and month which forever will be
stuck in my memories is probably the
most important period for our generation
and therefore I am so happy that
together with my friends and colleagues
we can open this exhibition of iconic
photographs because you know it very
well the photograph is very often worth
of thousand words
I'm sure that the photographs will very
clearly do the merit to the saying and
it will simply see how dramatic the
information that the the situation was
what was the tension in the faces of the
people and how not everyone was hundred
percent sure that everything will work
out fine what happened in the Velvet
Revolution was the fact that after four
decades we in Central and Eastern Europe
could finally enjoy the same freedom
which which way in which were taken for
granted in Western European countries
freedom of expression freedom of
assembly freedom of speech and freedom
of travel for all those born after 1989
for example my children
it's totally incomprehensible when I was
describing to them that we have actually
the Iron Curtain that fence just few
kilometers from our apartment and for us
to cross the river Danube and go to
Austria was something of unthinkable
dream when we look at Europe today we
know how much has changed and how much
we have accomplished I have to say and
now I believe that I can also speak a
little bit for our Czech friends then
together Czechs and Slovak we
accomplished a lot since well word
revolution 215 years of very hard work
we joined the European Union we join the
key military alliance NATO and we can
testify all of us that it was not a
smooth process but that we have to earn
it we have to reform we have to
transform and we had to deliver and we
really did it and therefore our both
countries are today very important
members of the European Union I would
like to conclude on the fact that also
today 30 years after fall of berlin wall
after the Velvet Revolution that we have
to appreciate the freedom and we cannot
take it for granted because freedom is
something you have to work for every
single day and this is what the European
Union's 10th words and this is what all
of us are working hard to deliver on
every day
to conclude I just would like to make
two references one to Alexander Duke
wanted to bring as a Slovak leader of
the product spring the human face into
the politics but also to what Slava
Havel who I believe managed to bring
humanism to the daily political and
decision making so thank you very much
to all of you for coming over here to
celebrate this very important moment in
our history with us I'd like to thank my
colleagues for making this exhibition
possible and I'm sure you will enjoy the
photographs and the talk and bit of that
memories we are very happy to share with
all of you of such an important moment
in our history thank you very much thank
you very much good evening WH er it's a
great pleasure and honour for me to be
with you tonight and thank you all for
joining us to remember these fascinating
days of November 1989 in Bratislava in
Prague and all over the former
Czechoslovakia and we know that our
revolution was held under two slogans
first one was free elections and the
second one was returned to Europe and it
was the call of Europe the community
that cherishes democratic values that
protects the rights and improves lives
of people that we wanted to belong to
and we accomplished our dreams 15 years
later when we joined European Union and
this was the moment when finally the
walls and the barriers that started
falling down in 1989 were finally
removed today 30 years later I'm glad to
say that Slovakia and the Czech Republic
reminds the closest allies and partners
sharing not only the common past but
also the common vision for the future
and we are proudly offering and hosting
this exhibition for you and I also want
to say that even today thirty years
after our Velvet Revolution it still has
a lot to offer too many let me mention
three points for
it's nonviolent nature namely the fact
you know it was not called Velvet
Revolution by chance and it proved that
democracy can be born without arms and
without violence second the way it
unified the nations and what started as
an initiative of some very quickly turn
into a event in into a movement support
by almost everyone and it shows how much
we can achieve if we want together and
how far we can go if we work together
for common good and thirdly the call of
Europe it was Europe that mobilized us
it was Europe that inspired us and
Europe still continues to inspire
millions of people outside of the
borders of the European Union and let us
not forget these people they are still
Europeans finally they say a picture is
worth a thousand words so I would like
to invite you all to enjoy this
exhibition it brings the story the
emotions the hopes of those fascinating
days and I hope it can still inspire you
thank you very much
thank your excellency the minister of
the Foreign Affairs of the Czech
Republic could not join us tonight he
sending his warmest regards but I do
have the honor to welcome here tonight
the Ambassador the permanent
representative of the Czech Republic to
the European Union his Excellency Dina
thank you it's good evening
WH era the reason why the minister
couldn't be here he is actually at the
pilgrimage to the Vatican to actually
celebrate 30 years of a major event
which started the Velvet Revolution in
Czechoslovakia and this is the patron
Agnes who was actually starting the
events in Czechoslovakia vieira marish
miss Lloyd Chuck excellencies guests
it's a great honor to be here and to
have the opportunity to tell you how
great we are how grateful we are for the
way we can celebrate 30 years after this
content and rebellion fight for freedom
and democracy thirty years ago we saw a
turning point between talk and action
and that was Czechoslovak contribution
to the world
we brought the name the term Velvet
Revolution to the existence no single
bullet was shot and that was unheard of
unimaginable when you would also imagine
that the evil of empire the the Empire
which wasn't collapsing so easily was
still there and without any drop any any
blood being shed that is what was
happening The Velvet Revolution or
sometimes
Slovaks and others call it gentle
revolution was later applied as a
chairman to describe the revolutions in
Poland Hungary East Germany and over the
course of
although seasoned months 30 years on
what happened in Europe in 1989 became a
model for other non violent
pro-democracy movements which have
triumphed in many countries since then
the moti Gordon - the liberal thinker
and essayist and scholar in his very
famous book year of miracles who
described it in a very clear dynamics as
it happened what took poles 10 years it
took hungarians 10 months it took
Eastern Germans 10 weeks and in a way it
took czechoslovaks
10 days the symbol of demonstrations
besides massive Havel and Alexander
Dubcek both were mentioned by previous
speakers
it was a cleaning lady it was a cleaning
lady who was prohibited any public
appearance or performance and suddenly
she occurred on the balcony on the
Wenceslas Square and now she is singing
the most famous song of 1968 the prayer
for Martin it was actually the Czech
humanist and philosopher who gave her
the lyrics Comenius the teacher of the
nation's let me quote these are the
words of the song which became one of
the symbols of the revolution
besides the angel the second one let
peace remain with this country Meli's
and we spite fear and strife let those
pass let them quickly finally pass away
now that you're lost governance of your
affairs is returning to you people is
returning the cloud is slowly flowing
away from the sky and everybody is
harvesting what Dave song but my prayer
speak to the hearts which by the time of
Eyre we're not burned like flowers by
frost like by frost
those words were used by Vasil Havel in
his first presidential speech on 1st of
January 1990 and I know that was our
Havel it's an inspiration to all of us
and I understand why and the speech he
gave to the European Parliament in
Strasbourg in March 1994 he said this
referring to the European Union if the
citizens of Europe understand that this
is not just an anonymous bureaucratic
monster to limit or even deny their
autonomy but simply a new type of human
community that actually broadens their
freedoms significantly then the European
Union need not to fear for its future
the task is convincing our citizens that
it is indeed what Europe is about it is
still relevant as ever and I think that
we all who gathered here today need to
embody the essence of this endeavour as
human rather than anonymous or
bureaucratic today we are far from being
perfect we face problems but of
different nature than before
most importantly we do not face them
alone but together in our European
family it is a testimony to the European
nature of the anniversary that we are
celebrating it in a prominent company of
the two European commissioners in the
seats of the European Commission with a
crowd of Czechs Slovaks and
internationals we learnt many lessons in
1989 we need to remember those lessons
not in nostalgia not in celebrating
freedom or not in fighting only for the
Freeman as it was 130 years ago but in
our relations with countries that are
currently unfree it was our mistake to
imagine that a revolution creates a
perfect government and society a new
normal irreversible progress this is not
the case I'm afraid ladies and gentlemen
The Velvet Revolution it seems has not
just
a past but also a present and a future a
model for now how the voice of the
people can be heard thank you
[Applause]
Thank You ambassador and finally let me
also welcome for the opening remarks the
host of this event tonight a member of
the European Commission Madame Dao Rafa
[Applause]
excellencies ladies and gentlemen dear
colleagues dear friends let us celebrate
today because there is a very strong
case very strong reason for celebration
well it's imaginable 30 years I remember
very well the Velvet Revolution we were
so young so fresh so energetic now we
are fresh and energetic but still I
remember the total happiness and all
foria finally we got rid of Bolsheviks
and a year before their betrayal
a revolution we we did not even think
about that it might one day come and
then the Germans the Germans started to
move and in Hungary in Poland everything
was suddenly moving and waiting for the
Czechs and Slovaks to move again you are
still young energetic and fresh Mirage
don't worry it didn't it didn't apply to
you well so we have a very good reason
to celebrate because Velvet Revolution
gave us a fantastic chance it gave us an
opportunity to work for freedom and of
course to pay the price for freedom and
we did it Czechs and Slovaks worked very
hard to have more prosperous and happier
country and perhaps today if what slava
Havel has a speech I would wish him to
be here with us believe me he would
maybe say our country is flourishing but
I think he would add economically
flourishing and it's not the same thing
the Czechs know what I speak about
because in one of his famous speeches he
mentioned in 1990 I think yeah pub you
voted him from this speech this country
is not flourishing he was
right so it was a great success and not
only the Velvet Revolution and the fact
that we got rid of totalitarian regime
we joined NATO and we joined European
Union so just let us imagine where we
would be without that I in fact don't
want to imagine it one of the satellites
of Soviet Union let's forget it
but let's not let's not lose the ability
to imagine it because I think it's very
important answer today I watched the
events in Berlin very carefully I was
looking after my two months old
granddaughter believe me it was
incredible moments she stopped crying
when Angela Merkel started to speak and
I realized wallah this young lady has a
good political instinct and I so I
remember well what Angela Merkel said
that there is not such a big war which
is impossible to destroy but many of us
have to add that the most difficult
thing is to destroy the mental walls
which we have which we still have it was
not easy to get rid of Bolsheviks but
it's much less easy to get rid of
Bolshevik thinking and we still have to
bear this in mind as I said the Czechs
and Slovaks worked very hard to live in
free and prosperous country and the
Europeans helped us a lot so that's why
I am so happy that I see many colleagues
and friends who are not Czechs and
Slovaks you who come
the country's because you were helping
us to join the EU I myself in the 90s
went to several study visits to United
Kingdom to France to the Netherlands and
the colleagues in these countries were
not only inviting us they were welcoming
us they wanted us to join the EU and to
to cooperate and it has to be reminded
and we should think about European
friends for inviting and welcoming us
yet there are not only positive things
when I look at this picture behind our
when you look at the faces I wonder if
there is such a demonstration today
whether all of them would say The Velvet
Revolution brought only positive things
there are many disappointed people the
people on the picture had a dream but
now the people know the reality and
these disappointed people they are
waiting for us to take lessons and to
stop making mistakes I think it was not
planned that in Europe we will have
winners and losers there are too many
people who think they are losers and who
were not able to come along with quick
changes and who now feel the frustration
of course when I remember the 90s in the
Czech Republic there was increasing in
equality in the society and many people
worked hard to be richer than others but
some not and they were richer
automatically because we had some
strange doctrine that no money smells
and that the economy must go first and
then
and it went to the detriment of the
whole society so still now we have the
people who think that the revolutions in
1989 were not successful that they
didn't work well for them and so here I
come to our hot presence there are
frustrations which have the potential to
install again authoritarian regimes I'm
so unhappy to say that and I am also
very nervous this is my sleepless night
idea that this process which we
experienced after 1989 may not be
irreversible and that we have to work
hard to keep democracy and Freedoms and
as mirages said I am the vice president
designate for values and transparency it
is by I am quite nervous about this fact
that freedom and democracy is not
irreversible because we have to work
together for the values I receive a lot
of mails from Czech people when I go to
the Czech restaurant the people come to
me and ask me what are the values you
will work on what is it but there is one
interesting thing Czechs are very ironic
people sometimes very cynical also but
they ask me what do you mean by values
and there is always edit we would like
you to explain that but we feel that it
is something very important and I am
happy about this and after these
discussions because it is clear that we
have to explain which merit values we
have in mind and that we must not be
alone with it if you remember Molossia
page
nature this is another Czech story he
said he was that the General Secretary
of the Communist Party and he had a very
yes energetic speech and he said we must
not be alone with our politics I would
not expect myself to quote mr. Kesh
today but I must say we must not be
alone
with our politics of protecting values
because we will need the people to be
with us what are the values citizenship
active citizens active citizens which is
something uncomfortable for those who
would like to have outer
Praetorian power independent justice
again something very uncomfortable
independent and pluralistic media again
for those who want to have absolute
power in the society it's uncomfortable
so me as the future vice president
responsible for values I declare here I
will be uncomfortable very much in case
of need so ladies and gentlemen I didn't
believe I will speak longer than than my
predecessors but I am afraid it's it's
true so let's work hard
let's take lessons but today let's
celebrate and let me finally thank
Anushka Gabriella and Renata for
organizing this fantastic event enjoy
your evening
thank you
[Applause]